if it's a good film you can make more
money than what Netflix is going to
offer you in that particular amount of time
and you might even be able to do it faster
where would you be right now
without Tubi I'm sure I'll be
moving forward with another streaming service
you know it just so happens that right now
Tubi is working for a lot of Independence and it
created a situation where you don't have to go to
um a lot of the bigger Networks like the BTS and
and things like that like you don't like if you're
on Tubi and you your movie is you know you've
built the audience and your movie is is strong
enough the storyline is strong enough to where
um people want to watch it you could actually
make more money on 2B TV than going and
getting a license deal or or selling a
movie to BT over over time you know so
um I think that I think that for me you know um I
think that 2B is just something that it was it was
timing because before 2B it was Amazon so I just
think that it's one of those scenarios where I got
into the movie industry at the right time and my
film was my first film was done at the right time
and so I believe that if I wasn't doing 2B
it'd be something else because that's just
what I do how many movies do you have on 2B
currently um currently we have seven projects
on there so there are circumstances
one two three and four um untangled
um a good day for everybody and the rise
and fall of cuckoo cow it's a documentary
and we have a project in post-production right now
all about a check that'll be out this summer and
we got a bunch of projects slated for production
this year and next year so more to come okay yeah
how did you get your first movie on 2B um first
movie I got it on there through uh distributor
so you know in order for you you have a film on
tubing you have to have some form of distribution
because you can't just submit a movie to them you
have to have either aggregator or a distributor
to get to them this was what year that was in 2000
and um my first movie went on there I want to say
was it 2018 something like that have you gotten
all of your movies on 2B the same way yes you
have to go to a distributor all of them all
of them and um I have relationships with a few
different distributors so you know and that's
sometimes that's good to be able to to figure
out what's the best situation for you right
it's no different than a a music artist who
goes through different labels or Distributors you
have to find the best situation for you because
what might be the best situation for the
distributor might not be the best situation
for you and how would a filmmaker know that that's
a good point well I think you you you would know
that number one um first of all by by knowing
that they're paying you your money I think that
would be good yeah okay that's the number one
sure number one and also you would know that by
um gauging how supportive they are of you what
what type of assets they're providing you with
to help you continue to move forward so um what
are they you know what what are are they just
collecting a check or are they actually there as a
partner as a voice in helping you to say okay well
maybe you should try this and are they helping
you with different um concepts with marketing
um are they putting up marketing dollars are
they invested in the project with you ultimately
not just saying okay here give us a movie and you
know good luck hopefully it makes some money right
so I I think for me right now I mean in every
situation it's different you know if you're trying
to get your first movie out there I think that the
biggest thing is to just get with a distributor
that has some integrity somebody that's gonna
pay you right that's number one so but but but
as you continue to grow and develop in anything
then that means you you are going to need more
from your partners right because you're
not going to stay at the same level
as when you first began so I think that that
as a producer you know when you get to your
second third fourth and whatever movie then
you're gonna start to learn that on your own
it's going to be certain things that's going to
start to click with you it because if you've made
four or five movies or whatever that means that
you are you are consistent and obviously you are
serious about what you're doing so if you did so
you're not just making movies that means there's
going to be other things that you're learning
throughout that process because you don't just
make all of these movies and you're not taking
in retaining no information so I just think that
you know ultimately to answer that question I
think that it's on the filmmaker to to receive
the ride as it is and enjoy the ride and and be
intentional about learning throughout the process
of what you need and what you don't need and
why not Netflix well um Netflix is is obviously
a tough for a platform to get on but Netflix uh
contrary to what a lot of people believe you know
when it comes to Independent films Netflix is not
really friendly like that with Independence um you
know they they and and and when I say that I mean
that you know what the licensing deals and what
not that they give out and I'm not trying to buy
them off Netflix I'm just saying that in terms of
um avod which is advertisement video on demand
which is places like to be um Pluto Youtube
things like that and then you have S by which is
subscription video on demand which is your Hulu's
your Netflix's in different places like that um
Netflix is S5 and and Netflix what they're gonna
do is they're going to license your movie out from
you and they're going to give you a certain amount
of money and more than likely they're going
to want it to be an exclusive deal meaning
that if you give a new film to Netflix you're a
fairly new producer or you don't have that many
titles you haven't put any you ain't hit the
ball out the park at whatever that might be
um then they're gonna offer you a certain amount
of money whatever that might be and it's not going
to be this high amount that people think so that's
why you see a lot of a lot of producers choosing
to go to a lot of other streaming services outside
of Netflix I mean it's just simply because when
you do the licensing deal with them they're
gonna want to control that piece of content for
a certain amount of time so that means you can't
put it anywhere else and a lot of filmmakers are
finding out that especially Independence that
you'll be better off just putting it on to me
and you know um and cash flowing that way because
over time you're gonna make if it's a good film
you can make more money than when Netflix is gonna
offer you in that particular amount of time and
you might even be able to do it faster okay let's
say though Netflix if you're lucky enough to have
prominent placement if people are choosing your
film do you think that's worth it even if it's
like a year contract and then more eyeballs are
on it and then once the contract expires you
know so so more people are You're Building more
awareness with Netflix definitely I mean listen um
it's all about what goals you have right so that
could definitely be a situation where you could
give Netflix to film and they could boost the
booster sales up and they could be strong for you
um I may assuming they could boost up the
the awareness of the film which then once
you get the film back once people know what
it is they might go click on it right but
to me that's a gamble because here's the
thing right how bad do you believe in yourself
so um do you have the type of
infrastructure and the fan base that
could sustain the same profitability for that
project in that ear because let's just say you
spent 150 000 on this movie or whatever
and Netflix want to license it out for
225 okay so you make seventy five thousand
dollars right and then you get you get the
brand awareness and you know you you can now tell
people I have a movie on Netflix that's cool but
you just would have to look at that as a
producer and just ask yourself what is your
overall goals because that is an option
right but I mean you might tell yourself
you know what I take this situation right here
just to get in there and figure out if you can
just build the relationships with them right
and then it might be one of your films where
this might not be one of your biggest pieces
of work or this might not you might not give
them the biggest um title that you have in
terms of you know you just might give them
something that okay this is an okay film it's
a good film but it's not your best work right
so I guess ultimately that's just going to
depend on what do you think is most important
for you at that time as a producer
are you trying to build relationships
because if you want to build a relationship with
Netflix that's a good way to get yourself in
right and if you have multiple titles and you know
depending on what you spent on the movie if if you
can turn a profit in that first year it might be
worth it so I will I would just say that you know
um just the way out all the options it's great
advice does 2B take every movie no um to be
um they take a lot of movies of course but I
think they got over 50 some thousand titles now
but um they're starting to be more selective about
the quality and one big deal breaker is the audio
you know um as the audio and
that's that's like one of the main
things that I've seen recently um that I've
heard from some Distributors and filmmakers is
you know the audio not passing quality control so
um you know at this point Toby is you know they
they've become a household name so of course
initially they was taking everything right
but now and now they they built up the
catalog to where they can be more selective
as to what they taken and I would I would say
that you know they're probably gonna give more
strenuous in terms of what they're picking the
titles that they're picking as they continue to
grow which is understandable sure so do you do
you always think about that or you know like lav
mics ADR different things like is that something
that you're super critical love is the audio for
your films yeah audio is is um audio can make or
break a movie audio can be the difference between
you get in distribution and you're not
getting distribution so that's because
creatively creatively when you're talking
about the picture right so the the actual story
I mean it's your story to tell however you want
to tell it right um as long as you don't have
any content in there that's that's like against
the the streaming service against their overall
rules of what they put on their on that streamer
service I mean they they'll pretty much give you
free reign as to the creativity right but but
think about it the audio is more of a thing where
is like okay if the listener can't
hear it then it's a it's a bad product